thank you both so much for
joining me today uh let's talk about
creation stories um
as i said right before the we started
recording um i have some individual
questions for each of you
and i'm gonna start with alan if you
don't mind um i
am very curious i've i've read all about
um who you are what you've done and
um the book and everything and what i
find fascinating is
you did a fair amount of drugs you
partied a little bit i will say
how did you remember everything
for the book did you have a did you have
a challenge
trying to sort of remember what was that
year like or what was that
month like and how did you pull it off
well i'll tell you the honest answer
me basically because i'm i'm i'm going
to get a good laugh about it right
before the book came together in 2013
i've got a powell who's a great guy who
even knows called harry mulligan
but there's a scottish expression of
total jk
he's a total jk and we we did a book
deal and and it was hard he was going to
write my book
but basically he got on he got on the
he got on the drugs in the drink and
ended up in prison right
but i had downloaded the book once
before
and then at that point i realized you
know i've got it
i've got to uh i've got to find somebody
else
so basically i put it all onto your tape
blah blah blah and work with this guy
look brown who basically is an editor
his own writer and he put it together
but i'd already got a whole book in my
head
because for two years i've been
remembering it and then harry get put in
prison
so then basically i that's how ending up
it was really easy to download at the
same time
that i completely get it with what i
find
amazing about your story is that in the
early 80s you're like 23 years old
you're starting a record label
everything that you did
do you think it's possible nowadays for
someone
to do what you did nowadays or do you
think the music industry has changed so
dramatically
that it's it's almost what you did back
then couldn't be repeated now
on one level it's utterly possible that
somebody could do it again but on
another level
the real truth is that punk
led irvine to be a writer and and punk
let me in to be a manager
and punks a long time ago now and
you know the punk generation are in
control of things like record companies
and big writers and
you know pr companies and you know some
of them are actually politicians when
you're playing right
i i i've got a little label now and it's
really it's like banking that's what
it's like
every everything's digital everything's
on a computer
everything's on a schedule it's a
different business
but i think there was a moment in time
that you could go through the door
after punk 20 years maybe acid house
after that kind of shot and oasis did
oasis were maybe the last band through
in that period that 25 years 20 years
after punk sort of thing
and they managed to get through because
basically it was
the label was run by old punk rocker but
that's kind of
it's different now it's very corporate
and it's very digital what do you think
kevin
yeah i just think that you know the the
environment in which we um
we create and manage and process and
promote
uh entertainment for one of a better
term
or art for work for a better term it's
so different that
it would be very very difficult to see
you know
because of we we we emerged from the
punk scene and through acetones but we
but we emerged from a kind of rich
heritage
of cultural heritage it came right
through um
from kind of mod and um and sort of
kind of rock and roll and everything was
everything was very it was very
immediate and it was very real you kind
of went to sea bands you went to
um you went to nightclubs and uh
whereas now it's like it's possible to
be
um an artist without leaving your
bedroom
um so it means that um
it's possible to to to promote and to
market
that kind of um what was produced
without leaving the bedroom
so it means it's a it's a quiet it's a
crowded marketplace but it's also um
it's also less of a qualitative fun
because it's not
it's not reflecting a lived experience
anymore it's reflecting a kind of
secondhand experience it's been passed
down into
into pixels basically isn't being
pixelated from for
you know so there's something lost in it
um
and um it's you know it's a it's a
matter of technical skill and just and
working hard
and and doing stuff but then it was a
matter of kind of um
really getting out and immersing
yourself and then seeing what kind of
came with that
it's interesting you say that about the
bedroom because i i watched a
documentary
about billy eilish uh and i guess her
and her brother create all their music
in their bedroom
which is crazy but enough about that
um a little bit more with you alan um
what is the secret to signing a band and
what's the band that still you regret
not signing
uh well i don't know if people want
bands anymore that's the real problem
you know what i mean but i mean i've got
a couple of new little bands are
absolutely amazing gulps
from a from spain and italy i haven't
met them a couple weeks ago
brilliant brilliant bands if the world
needs saving by a band
let it be them i've got another little
band the clockworks
iggy potlikes irvine white says they're
great um
i don't know if people want banjo so i
think
even i and i'm with the last bastion of
believing in bands even i'm a bit like
maybe
maybe it's just artists maybe it's solo
artists but ultimately for me it's
always just been the one thing it's just
songs
and i suppose if i'm being honest
i really like outrageous characters and
i suppose if you're an outrageous
character with a song
and i suppose that's the gala girls
that's bobby gillespie
that's kevin shields uh that's that's
the libertines then i suppose
i'm your guy because i get that kind of
weird kind of mixture you know
when did you first hear about creation
records uh i mean
let me start with that um oh
i mean really sort of um
i mean you know through the releases but
you know i kind of
but at first um you know i was assumed
that creation were based in glasgow at
the start because alan was you know from
glasgow and um
you know and we had mutual friends and
all that in common in glasgow so i
thought it was like kind of i thought it
was a bit like postcards at first and
then
um i was living in hackney and their
offices were just
very close to where where i lived and
you know
i couldn't i met people like mulreney
and all that you know and it was like
um and i didn't you know it was just um
i didn't really know that um that it was
a london-based label
at the time you know so uh so that was
kind of quite a
quite eye opener but i was aware of that
you know i was aware of the the bands
that
um that uh came out for him i liked um
i mean i got i got everybody like
everybody who got really into screaming
delica
which was you know it was a massive um
fabulous
album it had that you know the crossover
between kind of asset house and rock and
roll
um and um i love teenage fan club
as well you know so it was like and i
mean they
you know so there was a there was a
roster of bands
and i mean allen was kind of well known
from through glasgow but also
as you know as a guy who went out and
kind of seen bands and management plans
and was involved in bands
uh but um i asked i assumed that they
were
you know they were a glasgow based label
one of the things about
uh and it's weird to talk about your
story allen with you right here but one
of the things about alan's
life and his story is that like um
it could be this mini series of like
multi-season television
uh with you know if you get into the
intricacies of all the different
you know recording all the things that
i'm sure all the stories that
alan has lived uh you know that he's
gone through
um but you obviously made a movie and it
tells
you know um i guess what was the
decision
for making a movie was it one of these
things can you sort of talk about
um i guess was it on you at all or was
there ever discussions about
doing this as a longer thing well i mean
there's all those discussions i mean
it's like
this is a a game that um kind of
producers play they say like you know
write a movie script anything this is
what's better as a tv series or some six
part tv series
i think you kind of probably would have
what well as a tv show now i think
because there's so many characters i
mean there's so many characters that um
we couldn't actually feature in it like
you know that was just through time like
um you could take off and and show stuff
about any one of these characters i mean
the characters and the bands for example
i mean it could have been what vinyl
should have been if we had gone down
that route
uh but it was just decided that you know
let's just make a film and get
out and um and and make a statement that
way and it was a lot you know there's a
lot of um
it's a lot of really shy kind of films
like brilliant rhapsody yeah
and um the uh the elton john one was
they were terrible films and they were a
lot they were very much
that kind of um they were they were very
much these biopics so we had this view
of the industry as being this very
top-down kind of thing that the stars up
there and the star looks down and
everybody and every
we pay homage to the star and all that
um whereas we wanted to make one that
was very kind of punk rock very acid
house and um
as alan said one of his main interests
was just getting a bunch of lunatics
and um in a room together and he
eventually ended up signing me for
[ __ ] sake to
to creation like you know so he would
everything would um
and and the interesting thing that he
he did is he you you you liked um
russian be saying a song you should be
saying this but you
when you have to say that i mean it's
like you were interested in not just in
the
music that people were making but you're
interested in the personalities so you
were kind of thinking
man you know this [ __ ] might be a bit of
a waste of but it's a [ __ ] genius he
might just do something that's
absolutely outrageously brilliant yeah
you know what i think it was evan i
think it wasn't
conscious but i think this is what it
was i think i realized
if you sign lawrence
or you sign
nolan liam or you sign uh
like say moments they're all basically
[ __ ] a little bit damaged nuts right
and
that's kind of why it might work because
it's not boring
they're not bankruptcies guys everybody
on creation
in the 80s and the 90s would there was
not one normal artist
that we had everybody was a little bit
bad and that maybe did realize that
that that's why it's going to be
interesting because even if the records
aren't hit
the idea and the journeys yeah they're
all interested all these artists were
interested in their own way
i mean it's like and and you know you
you know
you might get something that kind of
crosses over as in this commercial but
um it was you know there's nobody else
that were kind of giving these kind of
people an
earring basically yeah oh it's true
and again it's like that now and it's
like i was actually thinking maybe i
should be signing [ __ ]
much madder people because that girl
i've got cat sfx she's basically pretty
mad it's like
maybe i should be like signing real
problems
well you know it's that's the thing it's
like it's not it's not a real
again it's a digital environment it
isn't really conducive to knowledge
because
nars go out and they go club and they
get drunk and they spark off each other
like you know they don't kind of agree
uh what the party line on the internet
is about everything
you know if it means social media what's
cool and what isn't and this is
how you should speak and how you
shouldn't and all that so that kind of
stifles a lot of that kind of lunacy i
think for you
so this is kind of different kind of
lunacy now it's actually a
an an introverted kind of mental health
issue that people
feel kids feel that they don't fit in
they determine
themselves rather than going out and
[ __ ] destroying the
world it's interesting also because
you know in the 80s and in the 90s
you could say and do a lot of things
that will get you quote unquote
cancelled today
yeah yeah i mean me another we won't
mention the artist but we were talking
about
somebody we had in the early 90s that
was so far over the line that you know i
mean
and then 25 years later oh not even 25
or 20 years later
25 years later just the world's changed
i mean you know completely i'm i'm
curious about the writing process
for a script like this how conscious are
you when you're
writing the script about the budget
you're going to have and the money you
have to
to make the project and how much are you
writing it the way you want to write it
and then you find out what the budget is
and then you adjust based on that all
right then
i wrote the script we didn't give a [ __ ]
about the budget basically that's the
producer's problem like you know you
can't write
if you can't write my money and you know
you can rewrite with money in mind
because they say we can't afford this we
can't afford that and
but you can't write money in mind that's
just um silly to try and do that because
you're limiting yourself
um by doing that for each of you guys
if you could get the financing for any
quote unquote dream
project what would you do and why
i would love to do a movie with um
a couple of uh about you know a drama
about
be a bbc executive who knew the extent
of the the
sexual abuse in the bbc in the 70s
and uh try to kind of take it to the the
bosses and
you know being covered up there's so
much document
the documentary evidence of that and you
get these horrible predators like jimmy
savol who's featured in the
creation stories and gary glitter and
people like that you know that um
uh and the whole whole sheriff all the
songs were basically a kind of
you know sort of hyper you know the
songs wouldn't be allowed to be made now
because they were
i mean basically kind of um hypersexual
songs about
um you know about quite a lot very
misogynistic songs now
um but there was a you know the
it would be an interesting thing as a dr
as a drama
to create um almost like a kind of
um uh a kind of last days of the empire
type of thing you know and
i think that um there was a there was a
sense of that
and that would be an interesting thing
to to do
i i would watch that yeah i suppose with
me
i mean i mean it's something that i've
always kind of
i'd love to do it but i don't know if i
could pull it off but i'd love to
the guy in the television personality is
dan tracy's ended up in a care home
and his story's [ __ ] tragic
uh he ended up where you know his record
company
when he was a junkie all his rights off
him i don't know if i've ever told you
this he doesn't even own his own
publishing in his records
they he they make a company
the early one well i'm not going to name
them they own everything he doesn't get
any of the money
he's he's skin living in a care room
that
in itself is like that would be an ab
would be a brilliant documentary
gentlemen you know
is there something in the movie that
people are going to think because you
have to obviously fiction up
fictionalize things when you're making a
movie because
you do and if you want the more
quote-unquote real story
you read the book but i am curious when
people watch the movie
is there going to be something in the
film that people are going to think
there is no [ __ ] way
that happened but it really did jimmy
savile
yeah i mean it's like the you know
there's an old you know phrase the truth
of stranger than fiction i mean it's
like
obviously you know the movie is you know
it's like you
i mean the movie is rock and roll to the
extent what is rock and roll you you
have to mythologize you have to i could
i
uh you have to get involved in
iconography you have to make it kind of
big and larger in life and crazier and
concentrated but
most of these things actually happened
the muslim happened you know
maybe not concentrated over that time
frame that gives it that shock of kind
of
um madness but these things you know but
not only do these things happen
there but they happen to everybody
who've been through punk
and it was through acetate and all that
and
every possibly every kind of band of
people that see that movie
can relate to a greater or lesser extent
and that's why it's been so popular over
here
last thing for each of you guys what's a
band
or bands that you wish more people knew
about
all the punk bands subway sets
television personalities adverts
the boys i love all these i love all
that you know i love some of the
scottish punk stuff but the jewel
and the exile and you know cuban heels i
wish all that stuff
was more famous but it's but maybe it
doesn't need to be because i know about
it and
the people that i know about it you know
i mean
i mean i agree well and i think when you
said subway sector
i mean it's like big goddard uh as to me
it's a bonafide genius like he's one of
those
um the genius songwriters to come out of
england
and um the subway set were known as
basically
kind of bernie rose's number two band
it's behind the classroom
but um subway select absolutely amazing
thank god ours
incredible sort of artist and musician
he's been doing this for years and years
producing this incredible body of work
which not a lot of people know about and
they should
and that's i'm glad i asked the question
on that note i'm going to say
thank you both so much for talking to me
today i hope the movie does
really well here in america and i wish
you both nothing but the best
thanks stephen much appreciated buddy